it was a massive display of women's
determination and empowerment
women and girls of all ages and sizes
were out on the streets of Chile's
capital
[Applause]
mothers brought their young daughters in
huge numbers
among them ten-year-old Dominique De La
Fuente
I used to have very low self-esteem but
then I started seeing on the social
networks that women are strong that
changed me
for the adult women here the right to
Safe abortion was also high on the
agenda
a draft Constitution was rejected here
last year and now it's back on the
drawing board but this time without
guarantees of legal abortion and gender
parity
it's terrible and it's even more
terrible the ones who are weighing in on
this are men
it's not a done deal that tens of
thousands of women who have come out
onto the streets of Santiago and other
parts of the country are sending a very
very clear message that they will not
settle for anything less than gender
parity and the right to decide over
their own bodies and that's something
that lawmakers and the ones who are
going to write this country's next
Constitution will have to take into
account
women's rights have advanced in recent
years in Chile
but we don't have the same opportunities
as men of my age so I'm here with my
friends to speak out for myself and the
many women who can't because they were
murdered
women like Marjorie Palmer her mother
says she was strangled beaten and
stabbed to death by her boyfriend last
August
for a life sentence for her murderer who
killed her out of jealousy
there was nevertheless a party
atmosphere
but suddenly a group of people described
by the crowd as anti-socials tried to
disrupt the March throwing glass bottles
stones and sticks
several were injured
they're ruining a beautiful day in March
they have no right
[Applause]
who they were but the incident seems to
underscore that women in this country as
in most of Latin America still have a
long way to go to achieve what they're
fighting for
Lucia Newman Al Jazeera Santiago